[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello i'm ben wattenberg
in the wake of the cold war russia
founders
its economy is broken there is massive
structural corruption and lawlessness
american businesses and politicians are
apparently implicated
all of which prompted the new york times
magazine to ask
who lost russia joining think tank to
examine russia's development since the
collapse of the soviet union are
lynne nelson professor of political
science at virginia commonwealth
university
and co-author of radical reform in
yeltsin's russia political economic and
social dimensions
leon aaron resident scholar at the
american enterprise institute and author
of the forthcoming book yeltsin a
revolutionary life and
michael mcfaul senior associate at the
carnegie endowment for international
peace and author of
russia's 1996 presidential election the
end of polarized politics
the topic before the house is russia
lost
this week on think tank
[Music]
[Music]
almost eight years after the dissolution
of the soviet union russia is in trouble
russia's gross domestic product has
fallen almost
50 percent since 1989. 60 million
russians are
said to be living below the nation's
poverty line life expectancy is down
disease is up billions of dollars have
left russia for greener and safer
pastures
capital flight over the last seven years
is estimated that between 200 billion
and 500 billion dollars
the bank of new york is being
investigated for laundering money from
the russian mob a swiss construction
company
is accused of paying credit card bills
for russian president yeltsin
and his family and vice president gore
finds his cooperation with former prime
minister victor chernomirden
coming under increased scrutiny
what happened some blame western
advisors who pushed for so-called
shock therapy measures urging rapid
privatization of state-run industries
and an end to price controls others
fought the international monetary fund
for not properly
monitoring its loans to the russian
government on a more optimistic note
some experts say
that what we see in russia are normal
growing pains
the clinton administration is urging
patients national security adviser sandy
berger recently wrote
reform will take a generation or more to
understand
corruption in russia we must understand
that it is
rooted in the legacy of soviet communism
but might not patients carry its own
risk
cash starved russia still has a large
supply of nuclear warheads and may look
to sell them
for cash to bad actors on the
international scene
might not the continuing hard economic
times give rise to a new nationalism
hostile to america and the west amidst
all this turmoil russia is gearing up
for elections to parliament in december
and a presidential election in june of
2000.
a few months later there will be an
american election and we will hear on
the hustings the question
who lost russia gentlemen
thank you for joining us uh i want to
post
three questions during this session how
bad is it over there
who's to blame and what comes next so
let's
let's start with that first question and
get a quick response around the room
how bad is it in russia today
i think you have to ask two different
kinds of questions to answer the big
question about how bad it is in russia
first compared to what and second
what question are you seeking an answer
to that long list that you started the
program with about
russia's economic problems nobody would
argue with that that things are bad in
russia when it comes to the economics
the question is compared to what well
compared to the soviet union maybe not
so bad
compared to how bad it could be in
russia well maybe not so bad
compared to poland most certainly russia
is doing much worse in this transition
than we would have expected but that's
just one question that's just one thing
that's going on in russia
there's also elections coming up you
mentioned that that means well on the
democracy front things are not as bad as
we might think
all right just hold that thought leon we
cannot say that things are bad
uh in a country which comes out of about
a thousand years of authoritarianism
three quarters of a century of communist
tourney dictatorship stalinism
essentially
and at the same time has held three
uh free and fair presidential two
parliament
one presidential two parliamentary one
referendum this is national elections
and now has elected governors in 89
regions again and local legislatures
this is the problem with this who lost
russia debate is that it's completely a
historical
and if you if you allow me to say a
geographical it's taken
russia is being compared to the united
states and western europe
instead of being compared to its own
history and to its own neighborhood all
right
lynn nelson i i gather you're somewhat
more skeptical than these uh
optimists here in addition to the
problems you mentioned at the very start
one of the more troubling signs that i
see is the nature of public opinion
itself
because it's people who are doing the
voting it's people who are going to
determine what the outcomes of the next
elections are
and those signs have been worsening for
some time now so that
is worsening in what sense well at the
present time
the russian people overall are nostalgic
for the brezhnev era
not only how do you measure that lin
siom which is the largest public opinion
research organization in russia they've
been asking people now for several
years do you think you'd prefer to live
in that time or this time
and what they've been finding is going
up it's going up and this year it was 58
who said they would prefer the brezhnev
period to today
and a full 50 percent now
express negative opinions about
multi-party elections
the dissatisfaction i'm talking about
gets to the heart
of democracy and free market i think it
can be said with no question that in the
early 1990s
russian people for the most part were
excited
enthusiastic and ripe for free market
and for democracy and that mood has
changed it has changed in both the
cities and the countryside
what what happened well the mood's
changed but it's
that's what happens in all revolutions
and i think that's what we need to
remember i teach a course at stanford on
revolutions and
throughout history it doesn't matter if
you're french russian
angolan south african the moment when
you're in
opposition you finally topple the onshot
regime
that's when expectations are incredibly
high
and it's you know i was living in russia
at that time it was an incredibly
euphoric time
and everybody thought overnight a year
was 1991 1991
1990 91 i mean i went to those giant
demonstrations 800 000 people on the
street
every weekend to protest brought down
communism
and then everybody expected well now the
revolution's over you know now we're
going to have two cars and live like
they do on tv
watching santa barbara soap operas as we
all were back there in russia
well it didn't happen that way now the
problem with the expectations
is worse than still by one yeltsin who
told the people
it's gonna last seven to eight months
and then we're gonna live better
and two by the west we promised them
lots of aid
we told them it's gonna make this
transition easy and then we didn't
deliver on that aid and it's
it's been a lot much longer process but
i think it is important to remember
this is the biggest change i think
transformation
politically economically borders of the
state in the history of the modern world
we're only seven or eight years into
this revolution i think it's it's wrong
to expect
that we would be at the end of this
revolutionary okay
second question uh who who's we're all
agreed that things are a long way from
perfect
and haven't worked out as well as many
people most people had hoped
um whose fault who's to blame for this
ultimately russia is to blame but a
large qualification needs to be added to
that
because russia followed some of the
tracks that it has followed
with strong urging from other people so
when russia was looking to create
a free market where they look they look
to places such as
our country where markets exist and they
heavily followed
some of our advice not all of it and
this is a deep subject but some of it
and we gave some very bad advice so you
are referring to professor jeffrey sachs
among others i'm preparing
i'm referring to the general approach of
rapid privatization without controls
without building law before we this was
also the position taken by the man who
was now the secretary of treasury
uh larry summers who was then with the
world bank that's right
and and they were in favor of what is
called shock therapy
yes and rapid privatization into
whatever hands
the property might fall they were in
favor of allowing
this kind of process to develop with
very little care and you prevent
corruption
you think not only retrospectively but
from that time at the time it was being
written about by not only me but several
others saying so it's a mistake yes this
isn't retrospective this is
things we were saying at that time and i
i beg to differ here
um we all know that uh you know it's
very difficult to build capitalism build
capitalism in the democracy
the mode of privatization contrary to
the you know established opinion at
least in our mass media
the mode of privatization actually
chosen in russia was extremely
uh mild therapy uh in the end
51 of all the stocks in about
uh what 90 000 enterprises went to the
managers and the workers
i mean this is a social on the
privatization the workers didn't get
their shares but
it wasn't the fault of the reformers no
it was a revolt of the directors who
who who took control over the reformers
perpetrated reform and didn't manage
to control these red directors who then
uh diverted the funds and and uh
isn't it sort of the fault of the people
who set it in motion if they didn't
follow through
you would have to have a civil war ban
let's let's go back and arm detachment
to every factory and dislodge
every director let's go back the
greatest dilemma of privatization
no that wasn't the greatest dilemma the
greatest dilemma was
what to do with this huge amount of
state property as we try to make it
private
now the supreme soviet had one plan and
that plan was to truly
privatize to the people of russia to
prevent them from selling their shares
in these companies for at least three
years
that plan was scuttled by chubias and
his advisors
in favor of the kind of plan that was
adopted that's just over that's just not
true that the privatization law was
passed in june 1992 the supreme court
of the supreme court this is one of
those this is one of the mistakes that
many people are making in history today
the supreme soviet never approved that
part of the plan
that was changed by two bias and it was
changed and implemented
let me through yeltsin's decree let me
ask a question
uh of you lynn nelson isn't it possible
and i i sense this is what i'm hearing
on this side of the room
that this apparent economic anarchy
is as we speak as ugly as it may be
growing what we call capitalism i
actually if i could i want to
distinguish between two things because
this debate needs to get out of the
kind of shock therapy versus not that
doesn't help the story i think you need
to talk about two things
need to talk about what economists call
macroeconomic stabilization
which is basically stopping inflation
balancing the budget that's one set of
things that's what macro economists do
privatization is what microeconomists do
that's getting property rights to get
right at the enterprise level i think 10
years out now
in these post-communist transitions the
overwhelming data
economic data shows if you get the
budget right
if you stop inflation if you get
macroeconomic stabilization
that's the best way to get economic
growth and the countries that did that
poland and hungary
are much better off than the countries
that didn't but there isn't an
economic relationship there and so to
bundle it all together and say
russia failed with shock therapy because
they they failed with shock therapy to
me is just such a gross injustice
to the real story of what went on in
australia it isn't that simple
one thing that needs to be pointed out
when we talk about poland
and other countries of the former soviet
bloc
is those countries had nothing like the
level of state
ownership that russia that the ussr had
they had nothing like
the centralization and specialization of
manufacture that the soviet union had
they had nothing like the level of
corruption that the communist government
had
so we're talking about apples and
oranges how bad is the corruption now i
mean every society has aspects of
corruption some more some worse many of
them
proceed for decades generations and
centuries and do
except for the fact that somebody's
skimming skimming money
they do just fine is this what is going
on in in russia or is it so deep and so
endemic that it is just
distorting the whole system then i think
there are there are several factors i
mean and again you know i don't want to
be panglosian i mean i think
i think it's my job i think the the uh
the elite is very corrupt uh but there
are several there's history there's
geography
and then there is political economy
history is that yes the country has been
corrupt i mean you read marquis de
christine who traveled there in
1840 uh corrupt completely corrupt
compared even compared i mean france has
its problems but
you know compared to france uh the
neighbors come and pick
the carcass and the problem is that
in every single country be it south
america
asia be it south korea be it
brazil argentina mexico even britain
under thatcher corruption immediately
becomes
the main one of the main issues in
public opinion and in politics
in other words apart from default and
that this is not to
a bet or excuse uh the personally guilty
i think there are very important
structural problems
for that corruption to emerge and here
the geography and history
and the transfer of immense national
wealth
from the state that guarded it with guns
to
private owners semi-private owners soft
owners hard owners
immediately produces a great deal of
corruption and the real question then
is this speaking of curves the real
question is
whether the russian corruption is really
what i call
a system systemically fatal in other
words will it go colombian
venezuelan wait hold hold on that that's
what we're going to come to
let's move into part three whether it be
an italian model
where where you could coexist with 25 of
taxes not paid
and still and still become a thriving
economy the situation has been described
very well
corruption was present at the time the
soviet union
was dismantled and that needed to be
recognized
it needs now to be recognized as well it
wasn't recognized well then
and that's why the privatization program
failed so badly because it should have
been seen
that these vultures were going to come
and that's why steps were needed today
steps are needed also
the situation is worse now than it was
then corruption is more rapid than it
was
did america in our role as
a newfound good friend did we
make any effort to uh
point that corruption out and to stop it
there's the contrary we largely
closed our eyes to it it was pointed out
by analysts
and most of that was ignored by both
american and russian policymakers
will someone tell us the story of uh
vice president gore and the so-called
barnyard epithet
are you familiar with what i'm talking
about well allegedly right he did get a
memo from the cia saying
there is this corruption with mr
chernamir and the prime minister
and he wrote a word that i don't think i
should say on television the question i
think
there are two questions there there's
one how how deep is corruption in russia
and i think we should be very concerned
about that and we should do everything
we can to expose it but the second
question is about
gore's position as i censored it
admittedly that's a pretty
brief statement but wasn't he saying in
effect look
this is the nation that for 70 years was
our
our our sworn adversary it still has
thousands of nuclear weapons uh it is
absolutely critical
that we'd be on on their side
and on board don't bother me with a
billion dollars here or a billion
dollars here there is a
a greater task before us and let's just
cool it i mean is that
what what you would divine his position
was i think so and i think it raises a
question
because there there's corruption in
russia of course there are
corrupt you know the biggest oligarch in
china is the the chinese military
they're the most corrupt organization
in china they're uh the the head of that
country for instance
puts people in jail because of religious
beliefs does that mean that the
president of the united states shouldn't
be meeting with the president of china
we met with soviet leaders who committed
huge atrocities
millions and millions of people were
killed by those gentlemen
general secretaries of the communist
party and yet our presidents continued
to meet with them
but meeting with presidents is not quite
the same as what we have done
with boris yeltsin we have put in boris
yeltsin the personification of democracy
in russia the personification of future
hope for russia and that was a huge
mistake on our part we should never
have personalized it the way we did
that's much more than meeting with
yeltsin and we've done that consistently
in the last several years leonard
yeltsin's biography oh i i'm always
puzzled by by this business but we put a
great deal of stuff and the russian
people put a great deal of stock in
yeltsin
in revolutions ben people matter i mean
it's true
that yeltsin probably uh starting with
98
i would say you know the star started
started to set
but in rebel i mean you know the gold
matter churchill matter lincoln mattered
maybe for a short period of time
in revolutions they matter yeltsin was
by far the best
hope for democratic russia and i think
the time
will show that he has left a mixed
but a very very uh important legacy
let's let's play a little game we have
to we have to get out now
this is 1999. uh let's make believe
it's uh 2009. let's look ahead
10 years from now and i say uh
might carry things in russia the year is
2009. what what would you guess
you would say well the two things that
worry me i guess
about the future i think the trajectory
are on the right direction on democracy
on markets
and on imperialism we haven't talked
much about that but we don't have this
messianic imperial power
in russia today and and i think if you
look at public attitudes and elite
attitudes
there is a much greater consensus on all
three of those issues
than most certainly than there was ten
years ago
the two things that worry me a lot are
one oligarchy capitalism
that is do the big guys that have
controlled the big resources in russia
continue to do that
and push to the side the small business
person pushed to the side
what i would call real competitive
market economy that's number one
and number two what i would call
creeping authoritarianism
i'm less worried about the bolsheviks
coming into power in some revolutionary
situation
what i'm really worried about is that a
set of consensus
guys come together win this next
election
and then through a quiet way break down
the press through a quiet way
arrest the opposition so you'll still
have elections but not competitive
elections leon i
asked for a scenario and i got an
analysis of on the one hand on the other
hand it's a common academic disease all
only fools predict
10 years of history but real fools do it
when you're talking about revolutionary
russia today
well i'll be right i i i i'll be a real
fool and i hope
uh the things i'm i'm doing for you the
uh
it's uh it's um italy
in uh the 1960s uh tremendous disparity
say as between palermo and milan uh
between russia disparities of wealth
well-being openness to the west progress
uh kind of corrupt or semi-corrupt
governors of regions uh elections are
held
the parliament is very difficult and
fractured presidential power
most likely diminished compared to what
we have now through constitutional
amendments
the press is boisterous free
people are free to express their
opinions everybody
is moaning and groaning and dissatisfied
the economy is growing three four
percent a year
so you're saying ten years from now
we will have continued chaos along with
economic growth
continued non-fatal chaos at the local
level uh
and and pretty much well-established
democracy not
of the anglo-saxon north western
european type
but southern european type now to close
this show we hear from our kevorkian
figure here
now why don't you tell me what it's
going to be like 10 years from now mike
referred to creeping authoritarianism it
isn't creeping it's rampant
right now and all the signs are negative
in terms of the development of
democratization
because you also now has more power than
the presidents of both the u.s and
france combined as someone recently said
a constitution that is made for a
dictator for someone who
uses authoritarian power so russia has
got to reverse its current trend it's
got to reverse the corruption trends
it's got to reverse the life expectancy
trends it needs to reverse the people's
disillusionment with democracy
can it happen it can happen but what
bothers me
is russia is further from that today
than it was in 1992
it's getting further and further every
year from that so
it could be reversed but reversal is
what's needed my two friends
are talking about a trajectory that's
upward i'm not seeing that upward
trajectory and if you look at the hard
data
i think you'll find it hard to see an
upward trajectory so it
can be reversed but it's going to be
hard and at least
we have a divergence of opinion which is
what programs like this are about
thank you very much lynne nelson michael
mcfaul
and leona aaron and thank you we
encourage feedback from our viewers
particularly via email
it is very very important to us for
think tank
i'm ben wattenberg we at think tank
depend on your views to make our show
better
please send your questions and comments
to
new river media 1150 17th street
northwest
washington dc 20036
or email us at thinktank pbs.org
to learn more about think tank visit pbs
online
at www.pbs.org
and please let us know where you watch
think tank
[Music]
this has been a production of bjw
incorporated
in association with new river media
which are solely responsible for its
content